in this dark hour
our thoughts our solidarity and our
resolve are with the Ukrainian people
they've been cast into a war not through
fault of their own
but because Putin knows that no people
will choose to live under his Bandit
rule
unless forced to
but the barrel of a gun
the consequences of Putin's war will be
horrendous and tragic for the Ukrainian
people
but also for the Russian people
who've been plunged into chaos by a
violent Elite
who have stolen their wealth
stolen their chance of democracy
and stolen their future
and we must prepare ourselves for
difficulties here
we will see economic pain as we free
Europe from dependence on Russian gas
and clean our institutions from money
stolen from the Russian people
but the British public
have always been willing to make
sacrifice
to defend democracy on our continent
and we will again
Russia's Democratic Neighbors
and every other democracy that lives in
the shadow of Auto autocratic power are
watching their worst nightmare unfold
all those who believe in democracy over
dictatorship
the rule of law over the reign of terror
in Freedom over the Jack boot of tyranny
must unite and take a stand
and ensure Putin fails
we must make a clean break with the
failed approach to handling Putin
which after Georgia Crimea and donbass
fed his belief
that the benefits of aggression outweigh
the costs
we must finally show him
he is wrong
that means doing all we can to help
Ukraine defend ourselves
urgently reinforcing and reassuring our
NATO allies in Eastern Europe
and the hardest possible sanctions must
be taken against the Putin regime
it must be isolated its finances Frozen
its ability to function crippled
and there are changes we must make here
in the UK
for too long our country has been a safe
haven for the money that Putin and his
fellow Bandits stole from the Russian
people
it must end now
and this must be a turning point in our
history
we must look back and say
that this terrible day was actually when
Putin doomed himself
to defeat
he seeks division
so we must stay United
he hopes for inaction
so we must take a stand
he believes that we're too corrupted to
do the right thing
so we must prove him wrong
I believe we can
but only if we stand together